[Music]
this
is congratulations
hi guys what's up dude it is
congratulations episode 2007 and the
reason why i said it like this this
[Music]
is congratulations
because uh it reminds me of jeopardy are
you recording on the thing it doesn't
say it on the numbers on the thing
we're recording and i don't even know it
so okay we started at that time and i'm
gonna know it uh i'm gonna look at it
from now on um so yeah dude everything
is good um
and i just wanted to thank everybody for
listening my fans to keep rocking with
me the fans of the podcast to keep
uh
listening and tuning into
congratulations the podcast and also
uh the patreon uh supporters you guys
are amazing um you can sign up for my
patreon
patreon.com and then also
follow me on twitch flex avenue been
having a blast on twitch uh it's fun did
i ever know that my life living my life
like edtv was good did i ever think that
it would be good no is it good though
yes it's fun i'm having a good time yes
dude and it's [ __ ] adding to my daily
life yes
is it probably [ __ ] doxing me
wherever i go and i won't be able to
hang out those places yes but that's
okay because it [ __ ] fulfills me a
little bit more in my life yes dude
still haven't been sniped on twitch and
uh people are always like don't doc's
where yard don't choose now we know now
they know he's near the bo burnham uh
he's near the bo burnham billboard on on
[ __ ] fairfax boulevard go go find him
and they're like dude you're going to
dock yourself what's going to happen
nothing's gonna happen a weirdo is gonna
come up to me and say hey what's up
dude i deal with weirdos all day long
people just come up and they are weird
as [ __ ]
so that's it
i i don't that maybe for not a stand-up
comedian
it's like a big deal but for me dude got
heckled all the time it's fine all going
to be good you know look that's fine
okay
um
so yeah dude and um
it is what it is but the reason why i
said this is um dude how about this
jeopardy thing man it's all [ __ ] it's
100 all [ __ ] this
is
[ __ ] dude it's a hundred percent all
all [ __ ] the whole deal is [ __ ] the
dude got fired for saying something i
don't even honestly i don't even know
what he said but i'm sure he was trying
to joke or whatever the [ __ ] i know he
was trying to joke and he said it on a
podcast a decade ago or some [ __ ] and
by the way everybody knew so here's what
happened a guy
since alex trebek retired or did he
actually he passed away did he pass away
yet
he did he died and i know that and i'm
not a bad person but i do know that and
it's not that i forget that i knew that
i just secretly
i don't know something something
happened
so i'm not a bad guy i do love
alex trebek i think that he's great is
it alec trebek or alex trebek i know i'm
kidding so um we do jokes here
so alex trebek uh passed away and that's
very sad he was a very very beloved uh
host game show host and he hosted
jeopardy and
he made the show the show you know and
when he passed one of the producers
stepped in they weren't sure
uh if they were going to keep him or
what they had like guest hosts and
and whatever it turned out that this guy
happened to be
um the uh the the um the ho the best job
to fill the the thing now when he got
the job of course he's a white guy and
everyone was like oh [ __ ] white guy
shouldn't have got it whatever he
actually was
you know
a a a fine host for jeopardy i think he
deserved the job because he
produced jeopardy
for a long time he was one of the
executive producers of jeopardy i
believe executive producers which means
top dog on jeopardy if not producer but
whatever either way he were behind the
scenes jeopardy became the host and it
was all good until
people got mad because he was a white
guy
and they
the the powers that be on the internet
or whatever drummed up all everything
old in the past that was gonna [ __ ] them
and they did and they said oh look what
he did what he did he called uh i don't
even know what he did i don't even know
what he did honestly i i didn't look
that up because i don't give a [ __ ] the
problem is he said it a decade ago and
it was on some podcast or something like
that and all these [ __ ] angels on
social media are now attacking him
holier than thou and saying he can't be
a host on jeopardy and here's the deal
dude the guy
the guy stepped down now here's my
problem with that okay here's my 100
problem with that
first of all the powers that be the
angels that are infallible that are
online and you know that they're
infallible because they have twitter and
you know that they're infallible because
they have read it and nobody ever on
reddit or twitter has ever said anything
bad or done anything bad
because even if you do bad [ __ ]
why would you hide out on the internet
under a [ __ ] pseudonym like lim
bizkit 68 or some [ __ ]
these are the people who are trying
these are the infallible angels that are
trying to
bury
some game show host that has a past like
waldo
all right
so jeopardy
buckled and i say jeopardy buckled
because
the guy mike richards the host of it
stepped down now we all know
if you have half a brain
we know
all good
we cough and we move on but we know
that he did not
willingly step down
we know the powers that be what network
is is jeopardy on the powers that be abc
this
is
abc's fault
[Music]
the powers that be at abc
told the jeopardy people we have to
protect the brand we've got to remove
him
rather than us firing him he needs to he
we're giving him a chance to step down
so the guy stepped down now here's the
thing
[ __ ] you jeopardy and i'll tell you why
you want to make a decision
you eat it you eat that decision you eat
that [ __ ] decision and here's the
other thing mike richards you make them
eat that [ __ ] decision but you can't
though can you no you can't
you can't can you mike richards and it's
not it's barely mike richard's fault
even though we can say well why didn't
he make them fire him then because they
were dangling the executive producer
title over his head they said well
either
you quit
or we fire you and if we fire you
how can you be executive producer now
that's the dirty [ __ ] game that
jeopardy played that is the dirty game
that abc played
you can't trust these [ __ ]
they're buckling to outrage they are
buckling to outrage and that's bad
because everybody even the infallible
angels they all have [ __ ] pasts so
dude be careful who you come for lim
bizkit68
[Music]
because one day they'll come for you
[ __ ] that man all these corporations and
companies they're holier than thou dude
these [ __ ] [ __ ] out there you
know what networks do do you know what
agencies do
do you know what these [ __ ] hollywood
types do they rob you [ __ ] they
rob you
they rob you
they make it hard for you to make money
they try to [ __ ] make the most money
they can and suck the most blood that
they can
and not give a [ __ ] they turn a blind
eye when it suits them
and they stare right at you when it
suits them
everyone's afraid of everything dude who
the [ __ ] hasn't been on a podcast and
talk [ __ ] about someone else i have
[Music]
cancel me again dude everyone needs a
youtube channel everyone needs a twitch
stream everyone needs a [ __ ] whatever
the [ __ ] i'm getting only fans dude
because you need that mike richards
getting only fans [ __ ] levar burton
only 60
sure that he also was in contention to
be a host not sure so if he's not not
[ __ ] levar burton and even if he's not
or if he is not [ __ ] the barber and we
did that for comedy so yes dude we're
firing on all syllables and it's only
been
eight minutes can't see it over there so
i have to look at my computer and my
contacts are blurry because i'm
passionate dude
when i get passionate my contacts get
blurry it's like my super power it's the
worst superpower ever but that's what
happens dude
i get [ __ ] angry like the hulk and i
don't get big and green but all of a
sudden my contacts just go
and then i can't see
so basically i'm daredevil
but it's like dude get it together stop
buckling to this [ __ ] [ __ ]
infallible angeled up mobs man
everybody's fallible dude you could you
know what if the pope did a goddamn
podcast could you imagine
i know guys who are [ __ ]
50 60 40 years old
that are like i think i might quit the
business because they
anybody has said anything
mike richards what was the guy from
jerry seinfeld's name
michael richards great cool so we
canceled now two guys named mike
richards that's when you know the [ __ ]
is bonkers we gotta [ __ ] get back
dude you're gonna cancel so many [ __ ]
people
you're gonna be left with a [ __ ] you
know what i mean a soccer ball and some
french toast
french toast is gonna be on the [ __ ]
thing this is in jeopardy
just a piece of [ __ ] french toast
with glasses on and a tie
sorry they canceled everybody i'm french
toast
here we go let's go to the soccer ball
soccer ball what is it
taco bell's like what is bottaswana
yes
we have to end it we have to end this
early i gotta get up early because
somebody needs to eat me for breakfast
this
is ridiculous
get it together dude it's 10 000 people
online that are just destroying people's
lives it's 10 000 people online that are
destroying people's lives
but what the [ __ ] do they care they're
lim kit 68.
they're hiding behind some [ __ ] ass
that's the other thing too i think it
should be illegal
for somebody
to have a dummy account online i think
it should be illegal you know how many
[ __ ] try to kill themselves
because another person out there is
calling them fat and they don't even
know who it is
it's [ __ ]
anyway dude i'm getting hot
i'm getting hot
one fire got an air dude every room in
my house has air conditioning got
central air my babies and that's great
except for this room and it's a podcast
room and why is that bad now it is bad
because why is there one room that
doesn't have central why the one room
that doesn't have any air conditioning
that's bad but also why is it
that
it's the only room that we're gonna use
to have [ __ ] crazy lights in it and
it's so hot now one fire was like let's
get a [ __ ] air conditioning uniform
so we did we got one of those one with
the long dick hoses that you [ __ ] put
in and you they scooped the air from the
other hou from the other area and they
put it and they cooled it from the new
area and
we did that but guess what he didn't
think of oh we have to close the door
and that big-ass dick hoes thing
can't be in with the thing and it's also
too loud so he [ __ ] up on two
occasions and that is why truly won fire
and that's fine
he's still one of my best friends if not
my best friend
however
that is why one
fire
so now it's hotty [ __ ] in here hey
yes in less than 10 minutes we turn it
off and close the door it less than 10
minutes yes dude i love only 10 minutes
of feeling comfortable
[Music]
i love only 10 minutes of feeling
uncomfortable and then 50 minutes of
feeling uncomfortable
you know i meant comfortable the first
time it doesn't matter we make mistakes
and we move on dude we have a good time
we make mistakes and we move on dude
so anyway dude [ __ ] jeopardy i'll never
watch it who cares though who cares
they don't need my eyeballs i wasn't
watching it anyway
[ __ ] jeopardy dude
they're just like they're just like
this is the see ya already daily double
and [ __ ]
my fan is oh it's not on he said turn
your fan on it is on dude it's not on i
thought it was on but it's not on and
it's on the thing and it's not working
and because it unplugged no it's plugged
in dude it's not in nothing's working ah
yes dude i love when nothing works and
i'm too hot sweat cascade down my
[ __ ] armpit dude
oh [ __ ] water drops are going skiing
down my lats let's relax dude let's just
relax let's relax it's fine dude let's
just relax the viewers at home don't
need to know how hot i am let's just
relax because honestly sometimes i'm a
cartoon to myself and i just want to be
real like i was last time when i started
the podcast i was real i wasn't feeling
it and i was opened i opened it i opened
up to you guys and i told you about it
you know not every [ __ ]
not every [ __ ] podcast has to be a
[ __ ] movie dude i love when guys say
that that's the thing that's a thing
that's a saying that finally put it to
bed dude
hey it was a movie dude we went to
barcelona it was a [ __ ] movie dude
quiet okay it wasn't a movie yo [ __ ]
dude coachella was a movie man
coachella was a [ __ ] movie dude
coachella was schindler's list
coachella was [ __ ] toy story 2 where
you cried at the end
oh my god we got emotional like
coachella coachella was a [ __ ] nyu
student short film
oh my god and you know that because
everyone was taking everything way too
seriously it's a [ __ ] movie
i don't know why i'm john travolta doing
that
but whatever dude
um i can't believe two guys named
michael richards have been canceled
that's [ __ ] crazy crazy wild can't
see anything because my contacts are
blurry all good
um
[Music]
i did
here i want to address something that's
so [ __ ] annoying dude
i mean i did a uh
i did i put a video out
kristin recorded me when i woke up i
told her about my dream when i go and i
woke up in my hugh jackman dream it was
like two or three episodes ago and
congratulations and do it now when i put
the [ __ ] out i put it on instagram i
also made a youtube clip on it on the
more crystallia channel go follow that
but also dude when i put it out there
this [ __ ] went
stupid viral dude the [ __ ] went dummy on
dummy bonkers viral okay and that's not
my fault i do the [ __ ] and then you make
it go dummy viral thanks but that means
when a [ __ ] goes
dummy viral right when i'm sitting here
going
because of how viral it went
everyone's getting it and you know this
[ __ ] goes dar viral when everyone starts
commenting dumb [ __ ] when the [ __ ]
really comments become serious
and that's what happened everyone was
trying to make friends in the comments
do it some guy was saying you know what
you can't say you're sober if you didn't
[ __ ] do the thing kids are sober if
you took xanax you went to [ __ ] zany
island all right dude drop it okay you
know the prob
stop acting like i'm a drug addict i'm
not all right
i'm not a drug addict and someone's like
well dude you say you know you say
you're sober guy oh you can't if you
went to [ __ ] zanussi island i like
how they were still using my lingo too
in the comments they were like you
[ __ ] said you went to zanzibar table
for two and that's actually [ __ ]
because yo you know it's a drug because
when you stop taking it you're gonna
feel that well hey guy i took it twice
they were both on a wednesday and they
were a week apart
last time i took it was months before it
so i don't have a [ __ ] problem going
to zantasy island i just visited
and it was a 0.25 and yeah i've taken
prescription drugs that's not what i
mean when i say i've never taken drugs
in my life ever that's not what i mean
when i say that i've taken advil i've
taken robitussin i [ __ ] you know what
i mean
i take also uh uh what do you call them
what do you call them ssris or whatever
the [ __ ] they call it is that what they
call them
i take them dude so those are the drugs
that i have done what i mean is i didn't
[ __ ] ever rail a bunch of cocaine or
go to toot on the [ __ ]
you know
on the weed train i never i never went
to toot on the we train is what i mean i
never drank alcohol okay
y'all could go to the doctors and get
the [ __ ] zany [ __ ] i got and they'll
give you a whole bar
i break the [ __ ] in half dude your boy's
a [ __ ]
good boy
your boy's real nice with them drugs
dude real nice i'm a [ __ ] choir boy
with that zany [ __ ]
but let's get back down to reality
let's get back down to earth let's stop
screaming about zanderson island i know
that sometimes things people areas they
rile me up nouns nouns rile me up okay
people places and things rile me up
but let's take a [ __ ] step back and
just relax because this podcast is my
therapy even though therapy is also my
therapy
and i really do appreciate you guys
listening i really do
this episode is brought to you by
transcend labs uh this company and this
is me telling you this
it hands down makes the best cbd
products in the world okay look there's
a lot of stressors in life
it's difficult to stay relaxed and
maintain a healthy mental state you know
this i know this anxiety levels are at
an all-time high of course they are
this is where transcend labs can help
their cbd is the highest quality most
potent cbd on the market and they have
third-party lab tests to back it up okay
cbd is an extremely effective natural
non-psychoactive
anxiety relief solution that can empower
you to take ownership of your mental
health
transcend labs voted the number one best
cbd oil for anxiety by l.a weekly have
you heard of them or do you live under a
rock
and has
since been featured on yahoo morningstar
and daily herald have you heard of them
or do you live under a rock
now there's a reason transcend labs is
constantly winning awards and being
talked about all over the internet
lately okay the stuff really works i
gave it to my dogs and honestly
they stopped barking as much okay
it was unreal
that my dogs
stopped barking this much but they did
they bark all the time and i gave it to
my dogs
and they stopped barking as much you
understand how good that is
dude it takes the stress level
down i'm telling you just visit
transcendlabs.com
okay and enter the discount code
congrats at checkout to get 50 off of
your entire order that's right
for a limited time my listeners can get
the number one voted best cbd on the
market for half off
again simply visit
transcendlabs.com and enter the code
congrats at checkout and save
[Music]
so yeah
um
that's about all i have to say about
that
but
my dreams be vivid
and i never had a dream be as vivid as i
was doing the hugh jackman one and i
wish
i wish he didn't even have to let me
know but i wish you jackman saw that
clip so he knew that even in his dream
he's better than me
um
yeah we still don't know when uh we
still don't know when donda's coming out
and i'm fine with that i don't really
care you know kanye's kanye and he's
[ __ ] losing his mind and that's fine
uh he makes killer clothes and
his music is
you know it gets worse and worse but
that's because of his you know mental
disorder and also he's focusing on
fashion i'm sure whatever and that's
fine dude and guess what the fact that
there's kanye west is fine
um
[Music]
one of my friends was like you know
taking him to task talking about how bad
he is for the world whatever dude for
some reason all bets are off with
musicians for
for some reason all bets are off with
musicians
but that shit's going to come out donda
the thing about music that is the most
annoying thing and i don't know if it
makes it better or worse but it's
definitely the most annoying thing is
that music is not about the music it's
not about the music anymore remember
when beatles were all like we all live
in a yellow submarine and now six
nine
is shooting people and [ __ ] coloring
his hair red rainbow rainbow bright
right it's not about the music anymore
it's about what [ __ ] kanye said it's
about the fashion it's about what lady
gaga wore
oh ever since [ __ ] bjork was that her
name with the swan
that was the [ __ ] that did it when bjork
wore the swan
it became not about the music anymore
she got so much publicity wearing that
[ __ ] swan that it didn't matter she
was just [ __ ] dude the cranberry saw
that and they were like what about libby
on her head
what about libyan hey
what about zombie what about all that
the pretenders proclaimers
proclaimers or pretenders
no the other ones proclaimers are
what about them they're like what about
walking 500 miles and then what about
walking 500 more
what about walking a thousand miles and
thinking about it when bjork showed up
with that extra arm on her hip
it became not about the music and now
kanye does [ __ ] like stream at a party
about how they almost killed their
daughter and aborted her before she was
even born
sad get him some help but it's not but
that's one of the that's the reason why
he's the biggest artist in the in the
world that's the reason because it's not
about the music anymore
kanye is fabricating and drake they're
fabricating this [ __ ] beef that they
have or they really have beef but either
way it's not about the music
you know
drake did a line that was vaguely shot
at kanye in a rap uh
in a rap song
and then kanye tweet or uh instagram
drake's address
too far
don't dox world stars
it's too far
and also
it's not about the music anymore
when you're out there doxing
[ __ ] you don't have to [ __ ]
[Applause]
you don't have to do that
you don't have to double inside
inside when you can just [ __ ]
wear a swan
you don't have to
why do you think janet jackson pulled
her [ __ ] titty out why you think jt
pulled her [ __ ] titty out
because they knew where music was going
you couldn't
this is why people are screaming hip hop
is dead dude it's not just hip hop
it's all of the hop
so it's like you know and by the way
comedy's becoming that way too comedy is
becoming
shock [ __ ]
what can i say for the most clicks
right what can i do that'll make
somebody [ __ ] follow me or click but
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] dude that's not what
we do here what we do here is speak from
the heart there's no agenda dude these
other [ __ ] got agendas dude i
have no agenda do not call me jeopardy
what you see is raw and real and what
you see is what you get i've been saying
that since tmp and the [ __ ] rolls on
dude
oops hit the [ __ ] hit him up too but
you know what dude i should have
that's why these [ __ ]
it's just it's you know
it's a weird time dude
it's not about the music anymore and
they're digging up [ __ ] uh you say on
podcast 10 years ago
and that's what makes last night a
[ __ ] movie
um
yeah what a [ __ ] move to tweet
somebody's address or to instagram
somebody's address what a [ __ ] ass move
dude
[ __ ] drake kept it to the song and
that's a [ __ ] move dude these rappers
think they're really gangsters
they think they're really [ __ ]
gangsters they think they're really out
here like someone who's not just ryman
all you oh dude let's just take a step
back you're right
let's just take a step back
you're basically a leprechaun
rhyme
let's just take a step back you belong
in a children's book so stop with the
[ __ ] gangster [ __ ]
right
so many rappers and hip-hoppers and [ __ ]
are just like oh dude you thought you
was a gangster till you met one
they do it so much that now [ __ ]
white suburban chicks are just like you
thought you was the gangster till you
met one see ya
you got homework
you know what i mean
if you have homework you know gangster
everyone's so [ __ ] mixed up and so
sad and so ridiculous i mean dude we're
acting like we didn't see this coming
we're acting like we didn't know we're
acting like
[ __ ] real housewives of beverly hill
real housewives we're acting like real
hapswice hasn't been on for longer than
a decade
survivor started this whole [ __ ]
thing too
i'm on one today but it's the truth dude
you're out here glorifying these idiot
[ __ ] housewives that are doing [ __ ]
like all they do every episode is
talking well you know she got drunk and
that was the thing we couldn't invite
her but she really wants to go but what
happened was [ __ ] rihann said well
you know we're not hanging out but we
were hanging out so now she found out
that there's a party and she's all upset
with us let's go to her house
well so what happened was and i found
out through that and i found out because
kanye [ __ ] put it on instagram
these [ __ ] idiots dude these real
hollywood housewives there's one of it
there's one in potomac
there's one in [ __ ] [ __ ] podomic they
made too many dude that's like the hack
joke
that's like this [ __ ] csi what this
one that the other the other
there's a real
housewives potomac
that's it dude
i swear to god they're making one right
now real housewives or whatever and
that's what it's called real housewives
of ah you guess that's the next one
coming out and these [ __ ] women
they're not even real they're cgi they
look like it anyway you seen those
[ __ ] with the duck ass lips
[ __ ] that their lips look like a whole
[ __ ]
they look like they're walking backwards
and they'll and then they open their
mouth oh wait they're talking this must
be their front
they look like the movie cats
these [ __ ] idiots and they're idiots
dude
all their hairs are just done
and they're just half of them have music
careers after 50 says what the [ __ ] does
someone have a music career after 50
elegances and just singing and [ __ ]
what are you doing dude and you're out
there celebrating that [ __ ]
you're out there singing it with him
elegance is learned
and now mike richards is at home and
he's got to watch this [ __ ] instead
of jeopardy so he doesn't have a [ __ ]
trigger attack
mike richard's sitting there
looking at a girl that should be walking
backwards
because he said some [ __ ] on a
podcast three three and a half [ __ ]
a whole decade ago
bro my [ __ ]
my girl and her friend just
burns through that real hollywood
there's so many
i gotta [ __ ] sit here and i gotta
listen all the [ __ ] it's always on in
the background
we've got to go to [ __ ]
they've got all the names that are
almost names
what's the [ __ ] name of the one teddy
no it's not a name
that's a [ __ ] cuddly
stuffed animal
it's like rhian and teddy and [ __ ]
piper and [ __ ] i don't even know what
their names really are it's like dude
what happened to [ __ ] you know what i
mean
kelly
what happened to tessa even or some [ __ ]
i mean call them ruth for [ __ ] sake
they're old enough
bertha and ruth they all look like they
look like the [ __ ] movie uh with
meryl streep and goldie hawn and and
bruce willis death becomes her like they
just wish for eternal youth and they
were like the devil was like okay
and they just [ __ ]
coming out of their [ __ ] bmw huh so
their husbands they don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on too they're idiot
husbands that are just like
okay they're just sitting there the
[ __ ] women are just hey
and the dudes are like oh i thought we'd
take a trip
you want to take a trip
that's all those old dudes [ __ ] do
you want to take a trip when we were in
and then the [ __ ] rihanna's like when
we were in
the the uh the south of france that was
when he first said dude who listen who
watches this [ __ ] and they're sitting
there talking this is the worst part you
gotta watch the show and you gotta
actually watch what's going on which is
the same thing every episode and then
you gotta watch them talk about it to
the camera
the they what something happens rian
throws a drink and then [ __ ] teddy is
on cuts to teddy and she's talking to
cameron and she's like sarianne got
crazy last night and she threw a drink
oh i gotta see the boring [ __ ] and have
a boring talent person tell it to me
boringly after that oh thanks but go
[ __ ] yourself whatever what channel e e
e dude
is it e o e dude
you're a bad network how's that
all this [ __ ] with to say yes to the
dress or whatever but we gotta come down
on that guy dude oh and the worst sh
episode of the show always is the
reunion oh dude
that cash grab of a reunion where they
all come back and they look infinitely
older and they're just like so what did
you think that [ __ ] guy what's his
name andy is it andy is it andy cohen is
that him
whoever the [ __ ] it is that good looking
dude with this with the silver hair so
what he's got the worst job i've ever
ever
ever i'd rather be a [ __ ] crack [ __ ]
than what that guy does
is it andy cohen
just look it up this is a [ __ ] dude
always crossing his legs so what did you
feel when when rhian threw the wine what
did you feel what do you mean how i feel
what [ __ ] cut to commercial
andy cohen yeah i bet you and that's the
worst j dude i used to say the word job
was ryan secret's job because all he
does is say this is american idol but
[ __ ] all that andy cohen's got the worst
job i've ever thank god he's rich
if i had to sit there and act like i
gave a [ __ ] about somebody on a reunion
[ __ ]
you know what sucks always reunions
they did their thing
they did it whenever hey journey's back
they're playing reunion tour
hey [ __ ]
remember this guy he's coming back
around and he's teamed up with that guy
now to help him sell tickets because
they can't
solely on their own
so we got all the old hip hoppers we got
big daddy kane we got [ __ ]
uh kumo d
and all these guys well why isn't el
ella coolja on it well because he still
sells tickets that's why
[ __ ] all these reunion tours dude when
i'm done i'm done you'll never see me
back on the [ __ ] thing on the ticket
playing for [ __ ] 90 year olds 90
years old
half of them [ __ ] stabbed me in the
back anyway but still
oh man but it's got [ __ ] uh you know
your boy got [ __ ] wicked today i
didn't even mean to but oops i got
wicked
for [ __ ] six dollars you can sign up
for the patreon patreon.com
and you get an extra episode a month you
get an uncut extended shits
uh and other there's another whole
review mode that i do that's a segment
what else do you want from me dude
i don't even give a [ __ ] if you don't
sign up but if you you know it's like
it's on you dude now it's on you i put
it all out there it's on you dude
can't believe the [ __ ] big lips and a
botox on these ladies and [ __ ]
and they're all working out talking to
each other in their home gym doing shits
that aren't even workouts they're just
like
that's not even a workout
what are they practicing [ __ ]
i swear i saw one of them going like
this yeah seriously we didn't invite her
and it was kind of actually shitty i
feel bad and she's doing just got a five
pound weight doing this like she's like
it looks like she's rock climbing on a
level on a regular straight level yeah
so
what are you doing strafing what is that
for
jerking
yeah
real real housewives of potomac you know
like what is it even called potomac all
i know is potomac river
um
real housewives
of potomac
season six it says
of potomac oh bravo it's on bravo
[ __ ] who watches bravo honestly has
there ever been a straight male that has
watched bravo it's just gay guys and
also women right look at these the names
of the cast
gisele robin with a y
candius
ashley karen and monique
i mean dude
like
how many are there housewives of new
york
i love to i love how there's new york
orange county beverly hills atlanta
dude and and kristen was like the new
york one's actually better we were
watching one of the ones and she's like
the new york one is actually better
because they just [ __ ] they're they
don't give a [ __ ] and it's like the nice
show i think one of them's got a music
career it's just like yeah
dude what's happening dude
it's like the jersey shore only only for
older women
remember when the jersey shore came out
and everyone was like watching it
and like
these guys got like millions of dollars
for being [ __ ] morons
whatever
[ __ ] more power to him dude
i'm in the wrong job i need to be a real
housewife of [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ]
we hit a i might i leave my parents
house
um
for we have dinner like every sunday i
left the parents house i had i had
calvin in the car and we left oh kristen
stayed home she had to uh
do something for school and [ __ ]
um
we drove back um
me and calvin and my brother had left
like five minutes earlier
and he wrote and he he called me as i
was pulling out of there of my parents
driveway and he said hey just so you
know on the two freeway before of the
mountain exit it's called mountain uh
there's a fridge in the middle of the
road
so be careful don't hit it and i said
cool thanks
so i'm leaving i got calvin in the car
and i'm on the two and i see
oh [ __ ] here it comes mountain's coming
up i wonder where the and as soon as i
thought i wonder where the i heard pop
real loud
and then
and i look
and about
not a hundred
yards in front of me not not even 50
yards
um i see
sparks and i think well there it is and
the shrapnel came from the fridge and it
started bouncing and it was bouncing and
i ran over some of it didn't pop any
tires or anything it was real little but
um
and i got video and i put it on my tick
tock if you follow me on tick tock
crystalia uh is my tick tock and it's on
there it's the last thing i posted at
this point it might be a few back now
when this by the time it comes out but
go look at it dude i got such a good
shot
of
the guy and there's a fridge indented in
his thing in his uh
grill and he was pulling over but he was
still driving he was pulling over i
don't know if he's pulling over slowly
or what i hope he was pulling over
slowly and i got the thing as i'm
driving by i didn't look at it because i
keep my eye on the road but i'm like i
and i looked at the video when i parked
and i got a perfect shot and i was like
wow that's amazing i can't believe i got
the shot posted it to tick tock i can't
believe i got the shot and so many
people were like commenting oh good on
you to slow down and help them are you
[ __ ] kidding me
dude first of all this is actually the
only reason why i didn't stop um i have
a [ __ ] toddler in my car and this is
america
i don't trust nobody dude
remember when tupac said i'm the way i
am because society
made me the way i am dude [ __ ] that this
is america
you hit a fridge and i'm with my toddler
you're on your own
i'm getting out to helping a guy in my
fridge my toddler's in the [ __ ] get
out of here this is america dude family
stays safe i don't know this
[ __ ] he was fine nobody was
dying
he just hit a mini fridge and it was
embedded in his grill i looked he was
fine
i didn't really look you know what i
mean
he was fine because he was driving
regularly off of the shoulder he wasn't
swerving and [ __ ]
um
so yeah dude but yeah [ __ ] all that if
it was burning on fire and my my toddler
wasn't with me i would go help
like [ __ ] jesus christ actually i
didn't even think of the brenden shop
thing he
took these kids out of this
car that was smashed and um
yeah and uh
well that whole story you can google it
but that's it's just insane that that
happened
um but yeah anyway my story versus his
is mine
and it was a little more heroic because
of how i saw a fridge
a guy run over a fridge and i kept
driving
but um
up with this milk crate dude can we stop
can we stop
it's a [ __ ] idiot idea oh dude you
know what i just realized i am an old
guy
but i saw old guys do the milk crate
challenge
with the challenges dude it's enough
one milk crate two milk crate
done that's my milk crate challenge one
crate two crates back to one crate did
it can i go home
bro they get up to six crates
and then as if that's not good enough
you got to get back down
for those of you that don't know they
set up crates they set up one crate then
two crates then three creates them four
crates then five crates then six crates
then they go back down five four three
two one and you gotta step from crate to
crate and it's like a pyramid and then
step down everybody falls on the sixth
grade for some reason the sixth crate is
the [ __ ] it's cause it's the highest
one that's the [ __ ] and then if
you make that you don't get to fifth
grade for some reason that step down is
the most spit you can be in your entire
life everyone is going wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait that's what everyone
is saying whether they like it or not
when they're going from six to five
and they fall and they don't fall pretty
man these [ __ ] flip and fall on
their either neck or head or right in
their rib cage the the crate hits right
in their rib cage
and everyone goes oh
and why is it fun
why is it fun
if you're a kid doing it okay kids are
stupid saw adults doing it what you're
doing you got a driver's license
only place you need to travel is home
dude
you don't need to travel up them crates
you're an idiot congratulations
you're a cuda
those barracudas see those flashy things
they hop right to them just cause
they're flashy that's what you did
[ __ ] that's what you did
oh you think i i can't do it
who did it rick did it
put him up
you're a cuda dude congratulations
but yeah man i mean how many [ __ ]
how many how many times can you see
somebody fall and you got to do it dude
i saw a [ __ ] fitness influencer doing
it and he did like uh
uh bicep curls on the top of it and it
was just like jesus christ
has people died from this yet well it's
how it's gonna happen they probably have
by the time this came out you'll read a
headline
uh
guy dies doing the crate
[ __ ]
milk crate challenge
whatever
i'm just like nah he tweaking dude you
know
i'm just like nah he tweaking
how about that [ __ ] on the instagram
that all of a sudden one day everyone
was writing nah he tweaking i posted a
thing and it just everyone nah he
tweaking and i'm like uh
did some really really high level
influencer tell people that
i was
i wasn't tweaking and they're just
disagreeing with them or nah he tweaking
then i went on everybody's [ __ ] post
nah he tweaking
bro shout out to whoever hacked the [ __ ]
out of the whole instagram
and and that was what they chose to do
could have been rich
you know what i mean
guy if you can hack
whole instagram
and make it so 900 million people have
na he tweaking 900 million times
under each one of their pictures
could have been rich
could he used that
to make your money instead chose to have
everyone read
nike tweaking
hey do the milk crate challenge
hey host jeopardy
hey
marry an old guy and be on real
housewives of potomac
because now you tweaking
um yeah it's crazy dude
now he tweaked it join only fans and
only show you with sweaters and pants on
dude how about only there's another
[ __ ] company i don't respect more
any company this is my impression of
every company right here this is my
impression of every company whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa okay okay whoa
whoa whoa never mind
that's every company now
whoa whoa whoa we didn't realize you
were gonna get that pissed off at this
never mind
only fans
well the bankers and the uh people who
buy our
you know uh
who who fund us are uh they don't want
nudity on only fans anymore now here's
the hacky joke but i have to say it
since this is this podcast and we talk
about everything
but
only fans
that's what you do
that's like mcdonald's mcdonald's
getting rid of
this is hacky but you got to say it
that's like mcdonald's getting rid of
cheeseburgers and [ __ ] coca-colas
acts like mcdonald's getting rid of
cancer that's like what they're doing
that's like [ __ ] j crew getting rid
of sweaters that only your dad would buy
and your uncle
j.crew getting rid of [ __ ] v-necks
uh vid v-neck uh cashmere
light green sweaters that's what that is
that's like canon getting rid of cameras
that's like what that's like dude
lenses
that's like a home builder not showing
up one day and been like why are you
relying on me to build your house that's
what that is
that's like [ __ ] new air is saying go
bald
that's what that's saying
sport your baldness that's what that's
that's what that's like
that's like the mlb going what bats
that's like kleenex saying you know
what's really cool
blowing snot out all over your mouth and
walking around town
that's what that's like
that's like sock makers saying hey
where tiva's
that's what that's like
that's what that's like that's like
hairdressers saying what
we love the caveman look that's what
that's like
that's what that's like
that's like politicians saying hey
us
that's what that's like
so what that's like
that's like radio shack saying
we didn't exist only in the 80s and are
still trying to do our thang that's what
that's like
that's what that's like
that's like trojan saying
splurtner
have kids
that's what that's like
swat that's like
you know what i'm saying dude
that's like smith and wesson saying
build the swing shot
so what that's like
okay
swat that's like
you understand
that's like home depot saying
don't hire the mexicans outside of our
place
so what that's like
okay so what that's like that's like
oakley saying
wear us even if you don't have chapped
lips
that's what that's like
see what that's like that's like [ __ ]
whoever makes those coronation shorts
say
saying hey buy us even if your dad isn't
a lawyer on cape cod swat ass like
okay
so what that's like you understand what
i'm saying
that's like the [ __ ] guys who made
the [ __ ]
you know
dick trimmers what's the [ __ ] dick
the pube trimmer shits they used to
[ __ ]
do our ads what are those guys that's
like them saying hey we're not trying to
be quirky and jump on a trend so what
that's like that's what's like me undies
saying hey
no more patterns swat that's like i got
me undies with [ __ ] soy sauce on it
and i don't mean i spilled it on it
i mean that's the bread swat that's like
swat that's like
okay
that's like me going to the gym
getting a membership at equinox or
24-hour fitness and saying you know what
i'm just gonna work out my mouth and
talk to everybody who's on the treadmill
from now on swat that's like
swat ass lie
that's like me man that's like kevin
costner shows up in a movie and halfway
through he says to whitney houston you
know what you'll take the bullets and he
drives home and goes to shakies swat
that's like sweaters like that's like
shaky saying go to mcdonald's sweat
that's what it's like
you know what i'm saying
it's like twitter saying use parlor it's
like parlor saying
use whatever the [ __ ] new one that
trump is gonna make you know
and it's like the new one that trump's
gonna make is like saying it's like
they're saying use telegram swat that's
hey what the [ __ ] is telegram by the way
is it texting or not my buddy lost his
mind he's on telegram anyone who loses
their mind goes on telegram telegram
what are ya
dudu telegram what are you i'd never
known no matter how many people
explained it to me
[Music]
uh what do you want dude
only fans dude
no
am i
you know that's one of those things that
i imagine
somebody was just like you know what
that idea is just so crazy it might work
[Laughter]
dude it's like little debbie saying what
snacks swapped us like
swat that's lie
it's like hindsight eat it dry squad
that's like
swat ass lie
i mean what the [ __ ] dude and then they
were like never mind um
only fans [ __ ] sucks now i was on
board with only fans
i was signed up to tyga's account no i
wasn't i'm kidding but that would be
hilarious i gotta sign up to tyga's
account on only fans i gotta get unonly
fans and only show shots of me and jeans
that would be so ill dude
just me and jeans i need an only fans
where i just promise you every week a
new picture of me and only jeans dude
i need a new app called only jeans that
you can sign up for and you put out you
in only genes and we do not discriminate
dude we have asians and whites and
blacks and indians and even people from
croatia with all with accounts and
they've got only genes on men women it
doesn't matter dude you could be a small
person a large person you could be
totally [ __ ]
the only requirement we have is you only
have jeans on and it's only jeans
you can't wear [ __ ] and then another one
a sister app we need only blazers and
that's all you wear dude just blazers
and everyone has a gun you can be a
famous [ __ ] person you come out here
you just wear a blazer now that's where
your dicks and [ __ ] are out and
that's fine but only jeans your dicks
and your [ __ ] are inside of your
jeans but whatever's on your chest that
shit's out dude
only jeans and only blazers
that doesn't only blazers doesn't really
have a ring to it like only jeans but
[ __ ] man you can make a million dollars
on only jeans
i'm sweating harder than i ever have
dude in my life
and it's the day we got the [ __ ] air
conditioning
i'm sweating harder than i ever have
six years of jujitsu work out every day
for the past seven years
and i'm sweating harder than i ever have
in this moment and that is unfucking
believable because it is the day
one fire came here and put the [ __ ]
air conditioning that he bought with my
money in this [ __ ] room and let me
tell you how much it sucks actually i'll
ask you
does it suck hell yes
[Laughter]
god damn dude i'd rather
eat 40 pizzas in the last 30 days
dude it's just
pitch
[ __ ]
goshen
but it is what it is dude
you know
better than being cold i'll tell you
that much i'd rather be in 150 degree
weather than uh
64.
i don't like when people are like oh i
prefer being cold because you could just
put blankets on dude every
chick that i've ever been with it's all
right i like to be cold and hot because
you could always bundle up and that's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing dude no
give me heat dude give me heat i take
the shirt off only jeans i have only
jeans on i look banging because i work
out and also sweat drips down my body
like a [ __ ] waterfall dude you're
welcome
[Music]
we have a good time on this podcast
somebody told me to get botox on my jaw
because i have uh
tmj disorder
i went to the dentist to get a teeth
cleaning and it was nice as [ __ ] dude
the lady was good dude she cleaned my
teeth up real nice man she was digging
and [ __ ] she was like i'm getting the
plaque i'm getting the tartar off and
i'm like hell yeah dude i love doing my
job too you seem passionate
she was just all in my mouth scraping
[ __ ] it felt good i got up and i felt
around my teeth and i was like did you
put new teeth in
kristen was on me she's like you gotta
get your teeth cleaned it's been like
[ __ ] a decade and a half and i was
like dude i brushed regularly she's like
i'm sure it's going to be a travesty in
there dude guess what they said wow
looks good can't believe you haven't
been in here so long and you've got no
cavities and barely any tartar dude i
win dentists that shit's a ruse only go
to the dentist if you have a problem
okay get your teeth cleaned sure every
now and then i get it it also feels very
nice and maybe it puts you in a better
mood but don't let them trick you dude
you need to go to the dentist every
[ __ ] six months my ass
you could suck on a [ __ ] muffler
every day of the week and still not have
to go as long as you feel nice
you can [ __ ] shove three musketeers
and i don't even mean the candy barking
i mean three musketeers in your mouth
every night for three hours
as long as you feel okay don't go to the
dentist
you know people used to die from [ __ ]
bad you know
teeth
in like the 1600s
because they had bad dentists they just
pulled a [ __ ] teeth out and their
your mouth would [ __ ] gush more than
my armpits right now
but yeah dude uh
my [ __ ] was fine dude
my my dentist came in the real one came
in you know how there's always the first
person there that cleans you up in the
mouth and then the real one comes in
which is like the most power move
like you you you go through all the
years of med school of being a dentist
and then you go through dentist [ __ ]
specific programs and then you open up
your own practice and then you're like
okay
i'll come in at the end and just give
the a-okay you do all the cleaning
that's so hardcore
i need to do that in comedy
i need to do that in a podcast
i need to have somebody [ __ ] come
here do the topics that i said just so
[ __ ] as best they could but not even
close to as good because this is my
podcast how could anyone do the podcast
you listen to because of the person
better than the person who does the
podcast
you know
and i have them do it in the five
minutes i come in here and i just kind
of like
i go like you know what that was that
was good that was cool i would have
changed this or that but it's all good
thanks show up next week and
congratulations bye with crystalia only
it's with someone else one time i was in
school i must have been in third grade
and somebody tried to do this is all the
inklings of me was were there
even in third grade somebody said to me
once
um we were talking about drawing
and my buddy said and my buddy was
saying like i i used to
like drawing and i i was pretty good at
it and somebody said my friend's a
better artist than you are i said really
he said yup because it was me and
aristotle we were the two guys who would
draw well me and aristotle arisata was
way better than me he really was um
as a matter of fact i think he grew up
to be like a [ __ ] architect or
something we got to draw real sh like
crazy shading and [ __ ]
um anyway uh somebody was trying to get
at me and they were like they were
trying to like you know make you know
make me
take me down a few notches and they were
like i know a guy that goes to a
different school and he draws [ __ ]
way better than you and i went [ __ ]
no he doesn't he said yeah he does he
could draw bart simpson better than the
guy who draws bart simpson and i was
like dude i may be in third grade but
you lost me do you know why nobody can
draw something better than a person who
created the thing
and i sat in that as a third grader i
sat in that knowing i sat happy as a
third grader in the point that i made
that i knew was correct and even though
they were trying to get at me and take
me down a few notches with this
real or fictitious character that they
said could draw better than me i knew
they lost the argument once they said
that once they said my friend could draw
bart simpson better than the person who
draws barcelona so first of all you
don't even know matt groening's name
second of all i sat back and i relaxed
because i just [ __ ] laughed and i
knew it was right i knew i was
right how can you draw something better
than somebody and i still to this day to
this day
i still feel
how i felt back then when that person
said that i can access that emotion and
that's what makes me a good actor i'm a
good actor too did you know that
you think i'm not
i am a pirate
well then matey why can i do this
har lock the plank
okay
so careful what you're thinking
[Music]
but yeah dude it's all good we got merch
that is out we got to go uh
uh
go medium and sometimes stay out and um
and we got to be more memorable we got
merch
[ __ ] flying off the shelves get it
while it lasts we keep having to re-up
and we're pretty soon we're just not
gonna anymore all the uh hot pink life
rips are gone dude and i'm not
reordering them there's still some green
acto cool [ __ ] going on and uh there's
some other ones too like the life rips
the og life rips we keep those in stock
because those those uh we love those
those are the og ones and then the
sweatpants it's fall coming up anyway go
to chrisley
uh dot com and shift around and don't
forget to follow us on flex avenue on
twitch we uh
play games and we [ __ ] just chat we
have a good time my life is edtv
basically babies so that's the end of
the episode on youtube and to catch the
rest of the episode and i'm talking
about the uncut episode head on over to
our patreon at patreon.comcrystalia
and uh you know every month we have an
extra episode of congratulations that is
not seen on youtube so you get that you
get uh there's another segment we do
that's completely separate from
congratulations called review mode where
i review [ __ ] uh that needs to be
reviewed and there's also uh behind the
scenes stuff and some other thing we do
polls we talk we chat there's a discord
where we do watch alongs with it's funny
[ __ ] so uh
patreon.com crystalia go on over and
check it out and uh if you do thanks if
you don't thanks also and keep
supporting uh like and subscribe
and leave comment don't forget to make
friends in those comments
and we love you
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
this
disgusting